yeah like I have to like realize like oh
that's my [ __ ] ego like we'll watch
tomorrow if you get [ __ ] is actually
tight yeah yeah I mean if it's paying
the bill Maybe
[Music]
all right so
just like I just said we've talked about
this here before the same type of story
just another group of people in a
different moment doing the same thing
but do they rape a lizard
thought it'd be great if we talked about
it from our perspective
and then see how we might feel or react
okay so in another 2022 headline a woman
stabs her boyfriend multiple times oh
[ __ ] after he caught her
making only fans content no that's like
cheating wait say that again is that
like cheating but she stabbed him a
woman stabs her boyfriend multiple times
after he caught her making only fans
content is that the content oh he caught
her yeah so she's making only fans
content he catches on he's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing she's like [ __ ] You
stabs him yeah all right so I'm assuming
business I'm assuming she's doing the
naked stuff you know what's funny or is
it like the feet stuff no way naked
stuff
here's the difference I think as a
factor if she was making content before
they started dating
that's on him that's on him for sure he
needs to stab himself dude if she's
swallowing mag lights and [ __ ] before
she ever met him turning the light on
that's a different thing and she's
making that throat glow
that used to be by the way they used to
be what talent shows were about before
they let the dancers in ruined it what
were they about swallowing things dude
yeah cool [ __ ] like that
a Texas woman was arrested after she
reportedly stabbed her boyfriend
multiple times when he caught her making
only fans content okay the argument
started early Wednesday morning after
the woman was caught
San Antonio authorities responded to a
call around 2 A.M about a man stabbed
multiple times by a woman in their home
okay her name is Nicole Jimenez Jimenez
with a G or with a J sorry I was like oh
wow the new one age 22
22
was caught by her boyfriend making only
fans content doesn't specify if it was a
dull content or not the couple started
arguing when Jimenez allegedly grabbed
the knife and swung it towards the man
he was slashed in the chest forearm and
ribs
which one which one's the kill you think
maybe the chest is he dead he's not dead
authorities I think maybe it's lit the
like uh because you got a rib cage yeah
you got a rib cage yeah so probably like
a a artery yeah where's the rib cage
part you want to roll your shirt up you
want to show us yeah show us
anatomically no dude he's too
intimidatingly sexy right now I don't
like it I like flat we need more views
dude we need the clickbait authorities
added that a six-year-old can you give
us a clip clickbait thumbnail real quick
before I finish article show us what the
ribs look like yeah
right here that's the [ __ ] thumbnail
what is that Authority Nick just made it
deal with the Devil
added authorities added that a
six-year-old child was present oh great
oh my God that's sad we'll just let's
forget about it and the man was taken to
a nearby hospital for
non-life-threatening injuries okay is
that kid go on a list like Social
Services no I watched the show Dexter
if you witnessed a murder in your child
you're going to become a serial killer
yeah oh [ __ ] that's what happens of
course you got my watch list the
writer's room at Dexter believes that if
you witnessed a murder and you're a
child you are going to in fact become a
serial killer and you're under a careful
watch exactly you should buy the
government you should be didn't David So
witness her murder when he was a child
that's why he's under watch that's why
he can't go anywhere that's why he's so
angry at everything
David is angry at everything but he's
just a Korean guy yeah like shanxi is
nice oh see let's not go let's not go
crazy yeah yeah see most hella nice
let's not go [ __ ] bananas David must
be an [ __ ] but he doesn't like the
nice Korean movie yeah that's all it is
yeah he he has no beef with the dude
what about his dancing moves he has some
pretty good moves or what no point is
guess not huh how would you all feel
if you ran into your significant other
you caught them in whatever similar
scenario in a state of only fans yeah
well I wouldn't stab them whoa but would
you use one of them aren't you perfect I
wouldn't go this is the perfect moment
to stab somebody okay so you're making
only fans content and obviously I think
you're a decent human so I think we know
that and you're doing it in secret yeah
and you're using a red camera wow I can
how can you do only fans in secret when
your link is public hey that's the thing
okay don't make it too real no that's
most of the people are doing it
most of those people are doing it some
people are doing it with a different
Alias like a username and not showing
their face right right so you can create
some like marshmallow the DJ I don't
[ __ ] know what he looks like right so
you create an alias you never show your
face but you show all the other things
that people are actually paying for
hypothetically right and these people a
lot of them don't have platforms
elsewhere like some of these people only
have only fans there's regular people so
you can go to only fans and then you can
there's like a category no you can't you
can't even right it's a it's a per link
per person right per account so that's
what I'm saying is you'd have to create
an alias account for your Alias yeah
why don't they have family logins for
for only yeah yeah I've seen people I've
seen people
um advertise their only fans on OfferUp
really yeah so so like no check it out
this is really interesting they'll be
selling like women's clothing and then
they'll like it'll be like a girl with
like a Scoopy top knowing that like
you're gonna run into that [ __ ] and be
like what the [ __ ] if you go to a thing
it'll be like oh my only fans is this
they put it everywhere but she's not
really selling any clothes yeah
it's just for the SEO wow oh yeah baby
so then they do they do it that way
because like otherwise you know you'll
know who they are and other things but
you'll just see like close sometimes
what the [ __ ] is this see garyvee
doesn't talk about these marketing
tactics so just so we have the spread
for our audience what would let's go
down the room what would you do if you
walked in on Geo making only famous
content and let's assume it is
the adult con with another man not you
but oh [ __ ] oh damn that's oh that can't
be with you that might as well not be
the only thing that's all it's just
it's just Thunder or something yeah okay
that's fine but not you you can't yeah
don't justify it with you I would say
when I was probably earlier 20s I
probably [ __ ] pissed and almost feel
like it was cheating even though I don't
know why but I think I just put myself
in a young brain and I just feel like
any type of like deceiving Behavior like
that is like what the [ __ ] that's like
borderline cheating even though I can't
even rationalize why it would be so it'd
be this immediate anger
um at my age now I think I would feel
almost disappointed at our relationship
at why we can't be open with each other
like why why did this have to happen in
secret okay if she's making a lot of
money would that change your perspective
like 80. no I'd be really happy yeah
almost to 150. let's talk about this at
a steakhouse
but I'm very disappointed at why like
and I'm gonna get the wagyu let me get
A5 wagyu like 150 steak and
what happened
what happened be open and transparent
what's going on and yes I have three of
the most expensive steaks but if she was
like I just want some
obviously you can pay for this easily so
it's so it's not
a deal breaker no I think um but if
she's doing it in secret yeah like what
the [ __ ] happened like why do you have
to do this in secret you know wow and
she's like somebody's got to take care
of a [ __ ] kid I understand why we do
this can't be running around just
[ __ ] working out and shooting guns
and [ __ ] but why why why you have to
keep that secret though I would have
said yes right off the bat well maybe
she thought you wouldn't say yeah you
know what as rationalize everything up
until that last statement that you made
was which I totally agree with like the
just the way that you would see it as a
20 year old versus a now minus the
steakhouse and all that stuff
you would actually be okay with it now
the only thing that you would be
disappointed about was the fact that she
kept it from you me and David been
trying to get her ass on only fans for
like three years she doesn't want to do
one well You Gotta Throw David in there
make it all weird all right well David's
gonna be our manager I'm talking about
nudies are you talking about like fins
that's not a bit that's like you really
wanted her to do it you and David
collectively collaborated on her
exposing herself when the cat came on
and she explained she was making like
300 G's a month or whatever yeah I was
like
what the [ __ ] yeah why are you wasting
away your life and she's written dicks
and [ __ ] yeah I'm like what the [ __ ]
it's such a like a it's a gimme it's
such a good cash grab if you even if we
just do it for a short amount of time
that you can like jump start your life
and we've seen people take stuff like
that like Kim Kardashian where literally
you just need like a cat like it's like
fundraising like for IPO if you will an
IPO IPO for your titties right you have
all this new liquid you say jugathon
jogathon and then you can use it
that's really good thank you for making
it better a married man wouldn't come up
with jokathon yeah and you could use it
to scale other things you know what I
mean and then you push so hard and the
other things no one even remembers where
this other part came from like people
don't think Kim K and think like ah just
sucking on Ray J's dick I do
but it doesn't affect her I mean you're
still my enemy
that doesn't mean we're closer no we're
not we're further apart you don't think
there's a disgusting there's a lasting
effect that maybe taika might go through
you're making it too real maybe well
that's because that's just the number
one thing people consider when they go
like I mean why not do the exact
question that's one of that's one of
them that's like the porn star's child
right yeah right which is the children's
book it's one of the considerations
that's obvious I mean that's impossible
but that's also like the pastor at the
church that finds out one of his one of
his
church goers is a porn star like hey I
was jacking off and I saw you you know
he he accidentally says he was jacking
off do you feel like you sympathize
because you were a delinquent maybe I
think I do I think I do probably
sympathize and I'm much more I have like
empathy for stuff like that and if
you're not breaking the law and if it's
extremely lucrative I think there's uh
less and less what is it called like
ego I guess because I think it's usually
when you're at scruples
principles
rules I mean but all those also dictated
by ego too it's like what you're
fighting for you know yeah where like
that's important to you where the things
you used to think real that's really
really important like you're like like
it used to be like not watching my wife
get [ __ ] it's like oh that was just my
ego
[Laughter]
why what about you you disagree I'll do
the videos over
[Music]